en plena época de festividades el
covid-19 dificulta las operaciones
aéreas con la variante Omicron
extendiéndose rápidamente incluso entre
el personal de las aerolíneas miles de
vuelos se cancelaron y retrasaron en
Estados Unidos en el aeropuerto Desi
Harol los pasajeros se quedaron varados
durante el fin de semana de Navidad
Einfluss o más
esperar 2 horas afuera con 6 grados bajo
cero para que un taxi estuviera
dispuesto a llevarnos a uno de los pocos
hoteles con disponibilidad de
habitaciones y esta mañana contratamos a
otro conductor de uber para que nos
llevará de regreso al aeropuerto
al mismo tiempo los funcionarios se
esfuerzan por encontrar formas de
minimizar el impacto de las empresas y
la movilidad los Centros para el Control
y la Prevención de Enfermedades de los
Estados Unidos han reducido el tiempo de
aislamiento recomendado para las
personas que dieron positivo de 10 a 5
días siempre que no tengan síntomas y se
comprometan a llevar mascarillas durante
5 días más también aseguraron que las
personas que han recibido una inyección
de refuerzo de una vacuna contra el
covid 19 ok estén dentro de los seis
meses de recibir su segunda dosis no
tienen que guardar incluso aunque hayan
estado expuestos al virus la institución
también afirma que el cambio está
motivado por la ciencia basándose en lo
que se sabe hasta ahora de la variante
Omicron para los pasajeros
internacionales que ingresen Estados
Unidos se mantienen estrictas
restricciones incluido el requisito de
un resultado negativo de la prueba de
covid-19 con menos de 24 horas de
antigüedad